something that people and what they do
but it's your accent that you're this
it's like it's the it's cuz your mom
told you you weren't good enough but
then there's so many things what's your
alternative we've all got our stuff and
I think that uh I think the quicker you
realize yes I may have more
self-confidence than you but you may
have things that I don't I just don't
spend any time thinking what all of you
have more than me I just focus on honing
what I have more than you 24/7 365
I think what's holding you back is what
you think other people are gonna say
about it the people that are scared to
fail stay was in a comfort zone and can
only hit a certain level most of you are
not scared to fail for yourself you're
scared to fail and then somebody else
that you care about is judging you I
just don't give a [ __ ] with my parents
or white kids thing my friends are
telling you something right now I'm
desperately excited to fail in front of
you because I don't really give a [ __ ]
what you think and B I'm gonna learn
from it and see battle scars are
attractive